- Dès que vous approchez
des écoles secondaires, des
affiches témoignent des vices
populaires chez les jeunes :
"Interdit de fumer et de faire
du skateboard." La plus récente
affiche : "Interdit de vapoter".
Le vapotage serait
présent presque partout.
Dans les toilettes,
surtout, où l'on doit
même mettre des écriteaux
pour rappeler l'interdiction.
Et même en classe, lorsque
le professeur a le dos tourné.
Mais voilà que la Santé publique
confirme qu'un premier Canadien
est atteint d'une maladie
respiratoire grave
causée par le vapotage.
L'adolescent de la région
de London en Ontario n'avait
aucun historique de maladie
pulmonaire ni signe d'infection.
Le jeune s'est retrouvé
aux soins intensifs,
la semaine dernière, mais il est
maintenant hors de danger.
Les autorités ne fournissent
aucun autre détail
sur la maladie respiratoire
ni sur l'âge, le sexe
ou la ville du patient, pour
des raisons de confidentialité,
de quoi faire réfléchir
au moment où le nombre de
vapoteurs augmente rapidement
d'un bout à l'autre du pays.
- Notre génération, en fait,
c'est la génération cobaye
pour le vapotage.
Puis qu'on va découvrir les
effets néfastes très bientôt.
- Je suis pas tant surprise que
ça. Mais c'est sûr qu'il faut
que les gens, ils réalisent
que c'est pas nécessairement
meilleur que la cloppe.
- Pour s'attaquer à ce problème
de santé publique, la ministre
ontarienne de la Santé
a emboîté le pas à son homologue
de l'Alberta et ordonné
aux hôpitaux de signaler
tous les cas de maladie
pulmonaire reliée au vapotage.
Elle souhaite comprendre
l'ampleur du problème
et développer des solutions
pour les jeunes Ontariens.
"Je sais que beaucoup de parents
sont inquiets des conséquences
du vapotage sur la santé
de leurs enfants, dit-elle,
mais il n'est pas question,
pour le moment, de l'interdire
complètement." La ministre
fédérale de la Santé se dit
tout aussi inquiète, mais
elle ajoute qu'interdire
les cigarettes électroniques
n'est pas la solution
en raison des risques posés
par le marché noir.
GINETTE PETITPAS TAYLOR,
ministre fédérale de la Santé
- Réellement, je pense
qu'on doit reconnaître
que de bannir ces produits
complètement va pas arrêter
le vapotage, ici, au Canada.
- Le problème de santé
publique est mondial.
Les États-Unis enquêtent
sur 380 cas de maladies
pulmonaires reliées au vapotage,
dont 6 décès. Puis l'Inde,
le troisième plus important
producteur de tabac
de la planète, a complètement
banni aujourd'hui même toute
production, importation et vente
de cigarettes électroniques.
Ici Philippe Leblanc, Radio-Canada, Toronto